buenas tardes es un golpe muy dañino uno
nuevo para la credibilidad de autoridad
del primer ministro que trata de
sobrevivir a esta la peor crisis de su
carrera política mientras crecen las
voces incluso dentro de su propio
partido del conservador para que
renuncie al no tener ya la autoridad
moral para seguir liderando el país y
seguir tomando decisiones por la
pandemia y es que la imagen de isabel
segunda vestida de negro con tapabocas
completamente sola alejada de su familia
para no romper las reglas del
confinamiento durante el funeral de su
esposo se ha convertido en un icono de
la pandemia aunque down instruida ha
dicho que johnson el primer ministro no
estuvo presente en estas fiestas lo que
cree la población en general es que en
el gobierno imperaba una determinación
de que la cultura de las leyes no
aplicaba para el primer ministro para su
familia ni para quienes trabajaban para
el entretanto el gobierno ha dejado
claro por estos días el primer ministro
estará ausente de eventos públicos dado
que está en aislamiento porque uno de
los miembros cercanos de su familia es
positivo para kobe pese a que ésta ya no
es una ley aquí en el reino unido